[Applause]
the world is coming to in it have you
opened your eyes yet catastrophic
hurricanes record hide earthquakes and
insane amount of wildfires makes me feel
like the world is coming to an end
California on fire
Oregon on fire Montana on fire Canada on
fire Texas underwater Idaho 5.3
earthquake hurricane ARMA is forming
look at this picture
fifteen thousand retweets look at this
picture my god it's almost like the
world is ending except this is footage
from 2014 Wow
and the more than 250 firefighters you
know no one said it better than Sarah
Silverman herself pray for Washington
pray for Oregon pray for Montana pray
for California pray for Texas pray for
Florida no no no no excuse me we do not
pray don't pray vote for a government
that believes in science
that's right that's right Washington
that's right Washington you should have
thought twice Washington should have you
should have thought twice Washington
before you started those fires
mother nature is real a mad okay I sweat
Washington you should I bet you should
have thought twice before what voting
for Trump Washington it was caused by a
teenage boy with fireworks no no no it
was Donald Trump himself that was Donald
Trump have you voted for a government
that cares about the environment yet huh
I also really like how this this this
what it doesn't have Mexico on it so
that suddenly Mexico isn't that
important sorry it's horrible this is
horrible
I'm trying to make some comedy out of
this but it's [ __ ] hard man it's so
disgusting to me seeing these
celebrities using these natural
disasters and you know blaming these
fires caused by teenagers to further
their political agenda you know whatever
side of it it may be the fact that they
use this to me it's so [ __ ] gross
it's these kind of celebrities that live
in a bubble
everything is so shielded from them
because these outrageous thought and
they don't understand how [ __ ] oh my
god cuz clearly hurricanes never
happened before as this picture from
2004 these hurricanes were fake
hurricanes okay just like fake news they
were fake hurricane the world may have
seemed like it ended before but know
that those hurricanes don't count okay
now Trump this is Trump's fault
everything is Trump's for these
hurricanes are you telling me hurricanes
happening during hurricane seasons my
fault just listen to Jennifer Lawrence
herself if you can get away with paying
somebody less than do it you know a lot
of people just don't choose the moral
high road and say no that's not fair and
I don't know or you could go
philosophical and say why are we so
afraid of women no yeah you got paid you
got paid less because you have a shitty
[ __ ] agent Jenn
first up crying it's also scary to know
it's been proven through science that
human activity that climate change is
due to human activity it's like well you
fly a private jet
anywhere you go Jennifer and we continue
to continue
well she's not lying there only voice
that we really have is through voting
but what the only thing we can do is to
vote so and we voted and it was really
startling you know you're watching these
hurricanes now and it's really it's hard
especially while promoting this movie
not to not to feel Mother Nature's rage
Ralph well I guess you know she's right
mother nature is angry America voted
Trump and Mother Nature wanted Hillary
to win Deerman mother natures are good
sends the Hurricanes you should have
voted for hey lemme take this [ __ ] dim
can you be my god how do you end up like
this
I don't understand it blows my mind it's
hard especially while promoting this
movie not to not to feel Mother Nature's
rage Wow because hurricanes never
happened before it's hurricane season
and they use it to blame the government
you know
bad people in power before you know
Genghis Khan Joseph Stalin Adolf Hitler
and then Donald Trump
that's when mother nature was like ah
you know what that's enough I had enough
you have now you will feel my wrath I
mean I hope no one I hope no one is woke
enough to know why this is happening
oh [ __ ] Jennifer Lawrence she's on to me
I don't find him confusing I I think I
know exactly what he is what what I find
confusing is how someone can use the
fact that people are losing their homes
from the floods and the Hurricanes and
you're talking about it to further your
own political agenda like hurricanes
have never happened before floods have
never happened before that to me is so
[ __ ] disgusting
when you don't even practice what you
preach you know okay one day I can
become woke that's Jennifer Lawrence who
you lost your home should have thought
twice before you voted don't you know
mother nature wanted Hilary I hope
everyone who's affected by the flood and
the hurricane stay safe you probably
know better than I do and what the [ __ ]
to do at these situations it just sort
of annoys me when I see people using bad
tragedies to promote their own thoughts
and ideas and so I wanted to say
something about it that's it for me for
now squad female hey